first of all it's fantastic to see you
guys where are you you're very
close i imagine that you're in each
other's bubbles at this point
we are man yeah we're in nashville we're
at my house we're in like i've got like
a little bonus room where
we've been making all of our records
recording i've got like a mattress
leaning against the wall
i've got blankets on the floor for the
whole deal but
yeah we've been uh you know after we
quarantined for a little while we got
together and started making me
music and yeah it's been it's been great
man having a little extra time to focus
on the music
the uh the the thing that we learned
very early on in all of this when we
were all going through it is that some
people
shut down while others got wildly
creative
totally i think that's how i think it
forces you kind of into that place you
know
which was good for you know it was kind
of good for us i think especially you
know with our current single i should
probably go to bed i don't think
that song i know that song probably
would have been finished
the way that it that it was and might
not have ever been finished at all and
we kind of had this time once we kind of
got back together and we finished this
song and just kind of i don't know we
were actually here
at dan's house uh the first time we got
back together and dan started playing
that song we had had a start on it uh
back in january
we had like a verse in the course and we
were just kind of jamming around and
kind of playing some stuff that we liked
and he started playing that song we
ended up finishing it and uh
kind of one good thing that has come out
of all this craziness you know
what uh having to go
what uh what did you want to say with uh
i should probably go to bed
yeah i mean the song was just that
sentiment
the title and the concept written down
in my phone for a long time and
we were out in l.a for the grammys and
we were in the studio right and i just
was like what about this concept you
know i always catch myself saying it
whether it's
you know sorry am i freezing up here all
right a little bit but that's okay
okay cool yeah i mean my phone it's just
that conversational thing of like
you know you you know you should
probably go to bed but you you go
against your
yourself you know your instincts and
you're just like ah screw it i'm doing
it anyways
whether it's a relationship or an x or
whether it's a
you know ice cream in the freezer or
something and you're like i know i
should
no and you end up eating the ice cream
anyway so just a conversational thing
but now that we've written a song we
can't use that phrase anymore or else it
sounds so corny to be quoting our own
song lyrics
well also how do you make sure that the
your wives know right out of the gate
that what you're writing is not about
them
i think they know at this point you know
being married to creatives we're always
writing songs and
kind of playing from different
perspectives you know i think everyone
can relate to a heartbreak song or a
love song i think
as uh musicians and as artists we have
to kind of be able to step into that
role of
actor and uh it might not necessarily be
something that we're going through right
now but something that we've been
through and
i think that's just kind of everybody
kind of has to do that because
at times we'll be writing you know a
song like tequila you know you have a
breakup song
and talking about you know thinking
about uh an ex in the past
you know after having that particular
beverage and
uh that's not something that we
necessarily go through right now
uh but something that we've all been
through including our wives i'm sure at
some point
uh so it's kind of that's interesting
because you know in this place that
we're in in our lives of being in
happy marriages and having families uh
and singing about
heartbreak uh you know is is a little
bit interesting but also kind of
you know it makes sense you know as an
artist you're writing those kind of
songs and pulling from
not just your experiences but your
co-writers and things they've been
through and
just being able to kind of be the
conduit of you know the vehicle that
that kind of gets it out there to us
people's ears
can you talk me and your fans and
everybody else through
what happens in your head when you
realize the success
and the absolute magnitude of something
like 10 000 hours
and how great that feels but then when
it hits you
as individuals and as a collective
knowing that you have to follow that up
that's a lot of pressure man it becomes
a lot more difficult to write songs you
know every time we write we owe it to
our fans and you know to everybody out
there in radio and stuff to
to keep pushing the bar and keep you
know stepping up our game and
yeah it definitely becomes more
difficult if we're in the studio and
we're writing with a guitar or whatever
it's like okay is it
is this hook good we think it's good is
it as good as our previous song because
you know we just got to keep elevating
keep pushing ourselves you know
everybody deserves that so
it is tough but uh you know whenever we
do land on something i feel like we're
both
like we're right on we're like okay
that's the thing that's it
you know we've kind of built our lane
we've we've built the dan and chase
sound over
you know seven or eight years now and
we've kind of got our thing and we know
right away it's like okay is this a dan
and shea thing no
okay we should maybe pivot change gears
and yeah it is a lot of pressure having
something like that but hey
it's uh it's a good thing you know where
it's good problems to have to have a
song to follow up like that
it seemed like a fantastic formula would
you guys work with justin again
definitely man is a super talented guy
and i think that was one thing that you
know
we've known him for a little while now
but we got together and shot that video
just kind of watching him he would sit
down at the piano and just be playing
and we're like
this guy is really talented you know
he's where he is for a reason you know
he has so much talent and
not just with you know songwriting and
and playing instruments and singing but
just his
overall presence you know what he kind
of brings to the table as a superstar
you know there's there's a reason that
that he's justin bieber you know
just saying his name is like almost
sometimes i can't believe it where it's
just like
he has one of those names where he's so
famous for like dana che
and justin bieber you're just it almost
sounds ridiculous in a way you're like
is that real life
if we really have a song that's that's
really crazy but yeah he's a great guy
and super talented so you never know and
we loved collaborating and kind of
having that experience was uh
it was a lot of fun for sure it was it
it was so good and it worked so well
because often times you know when
there's a collaboration or
two people from slightly different
genres get together and do something it
can work
but it does it's not it doesn't always
sound flawless and that collaboration
was so good
people immediately started talking about
you guys need to do a full
album together hey we're down we are
totally down for that
yeah if you talk to justin let him know
that we're interested
that'll be awesome it's a pleasure to
work with him and his team great folks
and uh he sounds awesome on the song too
it's you know we tried to tap into that
thing like the earlier justin bieber
sound where it was acoustic guitars and
cool drums and uh he nailed it i mean it
was awesome and it was so cool to see
the support from his fans you know not
only
in north america but around the world i
mean we were getting streams from
china it was blowing up there and we had
never had you know any activity there
before and it was awesome it opened up
our music to a whole new demographic and
yeah we're thankful for it man we'd love
the opportunity to do it again
um having signed with scooter braun did
you guys
take that as an opportunity to sort of
expand everything
about what it is you guys do knowing
that you could possibly bring it to a
much larger more diverse audience
because i think with any
genre country is seems like the genre
that is just dictated by the artists
like there's no real lane that you guys
have to stay in it pretty much seems
sky's the limit yeah and i think that's
kind of where it is now you know it
hasn't always been that way and
probably any genre you know i think it's
for the people who have kind of gone
before
us and kind of broke that new ground you
know in any genre obviously there's
always kind of those
you know you kind of have your staples
and it's uh anytime you go out of that
especially in the past it's been
difficult to do for anybody but uh you
know people like taylor swift coming in
and just kind of
being able to kind of do their her own
thing you know and to be
guys like sam hunt and people who are
really pushing the boundaries of kind of
now at this point it seems like a kind
of a norm which is amazing and the way
that
country music has expanded and kind of
changed in such a great way and really
accepted
different kinds of music and different
ways of getting you know the lyrics out
there with uh you know technology coming
along and
really creating different ways of making
music and uh you know it hasn't always
been that way like i said but it's
it's in such a great place right now
where we truly feel
that we can just try to write the best
dan and shea music that we possibly can
and
with that it's able to you know crush
his own genres and be able to do a lot
of cool different things and be able to
reach people
like i said in places like china or you
know africa all over these places in the
world that we've
never even been to before that people
are listening to our music and
really being able to kind of not have to
pigeonhole ourselves and
write one certain type of music and try
to you know kind of tiptoe around
everything and how we make music we can
truly be creative and
kind of open our minds and especially in
this time we have the time to do that
it's a really cool time in music and
country music too
and uh four cma nominations we have to
touch on this uh where were you when you
found out do
do nominations still mean the same as
what they did when they first started
rolling in for you guys
yeah man i mean i think they need more
now especially with the quarantine and
everything we haven't been able to feel
that gratification from
being on stage you know the immediate
satisfaction of hearing your fans sing
the words back to you so it's like
every little thing just counts that much
more for us and when the nominations
came in it's usually
tremendously early in the morning and
you know our phones start blowing up
it's like dude
are you seeing this happen and it's like
what okay that's awesome so yeah it
never gets old we never take it for
granted and
you know obviously we're competitive we
love to win things we want to win as
many as we can but
win or lose like getting nominated you
know multiple times
for an award show is is such an amazing
thing and
yeah it's always going to be exciting to
us man it keeps us going and
keeps us hungry for the next year you
know the next batch of songs that we put
out it's like
again raising the bar putting the
pressure on ourselves it's like all
right
this song got four nominations what are
we gonna do next how do we get five
nominations i don't know it's probably
unhealthy but
yeah i mean it keeps us motivated and
pushing uh pushing ourselves to be the
best we can
and then how do you guys manage when you
are putting together new material and
thinking about when you will be allowed
to tour again
uh when it comes to family because i
know that shay you have a couple of kids
you had your second right before
everything sort of went to hell is that
right yeah man it was uh
ames my youngest he is six months seven
months now
and we have a three and a half year old
asher and it was crazy we had ames two
weeks before our first
you know we had you know two we started
out the tour with two solo shows in
nashville at bridgestone arena
and i think we had him two weeks before
that so it was already just like a lot
going on in our lives and it was crazy
you know having him
and then you know now with him not
knowing anything obviously
he's so young he's not going to remember
this but being born during a pandemic
and something crazy like this
is just like pretty wild but it's been
you know throughout
all of this it's kind of been a blessing
in disguise of being able to actually
spend
that time and be able to be home for
little moments like you know him
you know smiling for the first time like
i didn't get to see that very i saw a
video of astra doing that you know
because they're touring so
i'm really able to experience all that
firsthand which has just been
i'm very very thankful for that and
wouldn't trade that for the world but
obviously missing touring and i have a
new appreciation for what my wife does
all the time
i don't know how she does it all the
time i'm i'm barely hanging on right now
i know i was i was just gonna say all
that great stuff and the dogs and the
kids
being around it's all wonderful but my
god how much do you guys want to be back
on the stage right now
oh man we're dying for it it's it's so
crazy to think that we're not going to
be able to get out there till next year
but
i hope it gets here sooner than we know
it you know we've got a lot of stuff
keeping us busy right now
we're we're working on music and staying
in touch with the fans on social media
you know i i feel like
as much as we miss it the fans miss it
just as much you know seeing their
favorite artists on the road all the
time so i think
2021 is gonna be a big resurgence for
live music and everybody's gonna be out
there full throttle and
it's going to be great man we're
counting down the minutes we're uh
yeah our wives are probably sick of us
you